thank you for the invitation and so
today I'll be talking about tensile
methods for feature learning I think
many of you here are aware of her in a
work intensive methods for unsupervised
learning of a wide range of latent
variable models we were able to show you
know many strong guaranteed results in
recovering the correct underlying
parameters of the model so here we'll
see now a different take on tensors and
show how they can be extremely useful
for feature learning all right so what
is the notion of feature learning so the
idea is when we have like classification
or regression tasks we'd like to first
find useful transformations of the data
and then carry out prediction right so
for instance for you know save face
recognition you'd like to first think of
like a bag of features maybe it's like
eyes ears and you know different parts
of the face if you can extract those
features first we hope to have better
classification you know and the whole
framework of deep learning is based on
the paradigm that there are these
hierarchical features where simple
shapes such as lions give rise to more
you know complicated features and these
are very relevant for you know useful
classification and in speech recognition
domain spectrograms and other
transformations have been you extremely
useful so the principle i'd like to
explore is how to go about finding these
feature transformations in an efficient
way and what can we say in terms of you
know theoretically when can we learn
such feature transformations right so
the idea is if i want to now predict the
label y given x there is some
intermediate function V of X that is
better for predicting y so how do we go
about learning these feature
transformations we can think of learning
them from label samples meaning this
function fee will incorporate both
information about the label and input or
we could do it just using unlabeled
samples so that means we can construct
these
arms using only the input X and in
practice in many of these domains there
are many more unlabeled samples than
labeled ones so it is you know sometimes
you look more convenient to find these
transformations using unlabeled samples
but of course the challenges in what
scenarios will not be relevant for this
particular classification task is
unclear right so these are all the
questions we'd like to address on when
we can find these feature transforms in
a principal inner end with guarantees
and so what we'd like to think of them
is in a model based framework so if you
think of a particular conditioner model
of Y given X we'd like to incorporate
these transforms as some latent
variables right so this is the principal
way to think about trying to estimate
these feature transforms it's a very
nice question so you try to find a
feature function treat a better put it
one now you have given unlabeled samples
how would that provide any information
about yeah so I mean because again now I
mean that's the question we'd like you
know you practice we also have some
distribution information for X right so
that could be relevant in knowing like
can you expect certain kinds of X and so
that we will see in the stock precisely
how that would be useful as well so
that's the question yes we'd like to
address and empirically people have seen
like good performance by using even
unlabeled sand samples for better
prediction so that's what we like to
address so you'll see that a little
later let's hold off so let's think of
like two cases for these conditional
latent variable models right so i will
have some distribution of y given x i'd
like to also incorporate these you know
intermediate feature transforms so the
usual way that you know people have done
this in practice is think of a neural
network right so there are now these
intermediate layers of neurons that will
finally generate the late
rather than directly from the input so
we can pause it now for a model that you
know the label is generated from
feed-forward neural network so this will
be one of the models will be addressing
so another model we can think of is I
know my like the classic setting is to
think of a generalized linear model for
the label given the input but we'd like
to expand on this and instead think of a
mixture of generalized linear models so
instead of like one lean generalized
linear model generating the label we'd
like to now think of it as a mixture and
again the question is when can we learn
the parameters of these models are in an
efficient way right so indeed in general
this is challenging I mean even the
identifiability question is challenging
right so if you think of a multi-layer
neural network when can we correctly
learn the parameters is I know highly
non-trivial and in fact you know
intuitively we know that if there are a
lot of linear layers we can just
collapse them so there should be
non-linearity to make a neural network
identifiable but also non-linearity
makes it much harder to learn so so this
is the winner first question that would
be natural to ask when are these models
identifiable but we'd also like to go
beyond and also come up with tractable
algorithms so indeed like maximum
likelihood estimation in these models is
np-hard the queer and in practice it's
you know back propagation or e.m all
these local search methods have no
consistency guarantees right so the
question is can we come up with
alternative methods that have you know
guaranteed solution that can correctly
recover the parameters of the model
under some very you know reasonable
conditions and indeed we also would like
to worry about sample complexity because
we are thinking of these models in high
dimensions so we'd like to have models
that are low sample complexity ideally
some in Al order polynomial in the input
dimension and so we'll see how tensor
methods can lead to like guaranteed
learning for this class of conditioner
latent variable models and there are
some you know under some set of
conditions so we'll see what those are
so indeed I know but I'm sure many of
you here are aware of the basic spectral
methods so these are matrix operations
which involve finding a low-dimensional
you know projections of the data right
so there's the basic PCA where you'd
like to find a low dimensional subspace
that captures the data well or you can
think of the CCA setting when there are
multiple views of the data I would like
to find the maximizing canonical
correlation directions and these involve
are you know spectral decomposition of
matrices but what we'd like to see is
can we go beyond two tensors right so
can we pca and CCA only work on like
pairwise relationships can we think
about higher order moments and can we
decompose them efficiently to learn
parameters of a wide range of
probabilistic models and indeed we can
think of you know representing these
higher order moments and that's where
the tensor framework comes up so but if
you think of a matrix we can think of
you know the indices of these matrices
representing correlation between every
pairs of our variables now if you think
of say a tall order tensor similarly we
can think of the tensor incorporating
the you know third order moment for
every triplet of variables so we can you
know represent moments in this form and
now the question is what can we do with
transfers right so we can similarly
define a spectral decomposition similar
to the matrix eigenvalue problem so the
matrix we'd like to find the most
compact you know some of Rank 1 terms
that fits the matrix similarly for the
tensor the notion of a CP decomposition
is to find the best decomposition of the
transfer into some of Rank 1 terms and
indeed this is also a non convex problem
and the question is you know is this
guaranteed
converge to the right solution and you
know and what I we had earlier analysis
and that was indeed in a work even
before us that showed that in many cases
indeed that we can correctly get the
solution so one of the cases is the
orthogonal setting so if these
components are orthogonal to one another
then we can correctly recover the you
know decomposition of a chancer we can
get the global convergence in that
setting and in deeds of you know what we
saw was not just for orthogonal tensors
even if the components are
non-orthogonal if they are linearly
independent that suffices to get the
correct decomposition so it's so you see
here going from matrices two tensors we
get more information here in the matrix
you can only recognize the components up
to an orthogonal representation but with
tensors we can also recover
non-orthogonal representations and in
and in fact in our most recent work with
in a wrong way and much eat my student
what we have shown is we can even
recover over complete representations so
for a chancer we can have
identifiability even when the rank is
more than the dimension right there more
number of terms than the input
dimensionality and for a matrix this is
impossible so which answers we can now
extract you know much better information
than you know using matrix operations so
tensors are indeed very powerful for
learning a range of latent variable
models so the question we'd like to
address now is how can we learn
conditional models using these strands
of methods right so now with conditional
model we have label and we have input
and so we can construct different kinds
of moments we can construct you know
this the usual like cross moment between
the label and the input but we can also
now construct higher order moments and
now there is no reason to limit you just
you know these linear versions or multi
linear versions of input
turn the label right so we can also
think of having some feature
transformations of the input and use
that to construct the moments so the
question is what is the right feature
transformation to construct these
moments so that's how we will think of
feature learning in the sense that we
want to find good transformations of the
input that will lead to efficient
construction of these moments and of
course the question is what will these
moments reveal and if i do spectral
decomposition of these moments what can
i what kind of conditional latent
variable models can I learn efficiently
so that's what we'd like to address in
this talk so we are now taking it this
is a different take on flower feature
learning because we want to think of
learning first features in order to
construct these cross moments between
those feature transformations of the
input and the label and then exploit
them for learning these conditional
latent variable models so so what we'll
see is sites are you know very useful to
construct these feature transformations
based on the input distribution so this
is why the input distribution also
matters because here if you think of
these moments between the input and the
label it includes the Joint Distribution
of both the input and the label so it's
not just the conditional distribution of
the label given the input that matters
but also this joint distribution and so
we'll think of we'll see what kinds of
these features are can be constructed
that will be useful for such cross
moment construction so let's see I know
let's incorporate now a generative model
for the input and lets you know first
I'll show you some possible feature
constructions and then I'll justify why
they are the right wants to look at and
so the popular one that's being Niner
used before is the so-called score
function which is the gradient of the
log of the density function so in this
example if there is this one-dimensional
density function
and constructed score and intuitively
that captures like local variations of
the density function perhaps it's more
visible in this two-dimensional you know
the famous visual example so this is the
density function and the vector field
here now represents this core function
so intuitively these core functions are
representing local variations in the
density function right so and these core
functions have been used before for you
know as features are in many settings
and the strength of these methods are
like work even for non-normalized models
so if you pause it like restricted
Boltzmann machines where partition
function is intractable if you look at
this gradient right the partition
function disappears so they become
tractable for estimating non-normalized
models so that's the context where score
functions have been used before and to
estimate this we only need unlabeled
samples so that's the good thing because
we can now have used a lot of unlabeled
samples and construct you know estimate
these core functions efficiently right
and also there has been recent work by
aline and benji o which shows that you
know you can do quick approximations of
these score functions using auto
encoders assuming you go to the optimal
reconstruction in the order encoder so
you know so the idea is one option is to
incorporate these core functions as the
transformations to construct the cross
moments right so we can use this score
function feature instead of directly the
input to find the cross moment between
the label and now this you know score
function feature but what is the
drawback the drawback is if we can think
of X as a vector right so we have vector
inputs the score function is again just
a vector so this way we can only
construct you know like just the first
order cross moment between the two right
so we can also say why is the scalar as
in the simple case of binary
classification then this moment
is just a vector so but we'd like to now
go two tenses we would like to go to
these higher order moments so is there a
you know hierarchy of such functions
that can be used to construct these you
know cross moments so what we came up
with I is this you know notion of
looking at now higher-order derivatives
of the input distribution so we call
them higher orders core functions and
now this way we can now have
progressively higher dimensional
features right quick so now say if X is
a vector now the second order version
would be a matrix the third order score
function is a tensor and so on so now if
you incorporate them into constructing
these cross moments we can now get this
whole hierarchy of moments go ranging
from matrices to higher order tensors so
this way we now have the flexibility to
have moments of any order so now the
question is why is this the right
transformation why are these moments the
right wants to look at so right so we'll
look at this cross moment between the
label and these core functions so the
result what we establish is in fact what
are these moments revealing so they are
nothing but the expected values of the
gradient of the label as a function of
input so know this g of x is nothing but
the conditional expectation of the label
given the input and if we look at these
cross moment of the label with respect
to the store functions what we obtain
our expected radiance of this function
so this results I mean there's the
classical steins lemma which is which
was you know which is for like order 1
and usually it's you know shown for
Gaussian distributions but it's a
straightforward extension to also think
about more general distributions and so
for any continuous distribution we have
this result that by looking at these
higher orders core function we can get
access to expected gradients of the
label as a function of the input so
that's why we call
all this framework as you know an
approach to have a discriminative
information right because we are you
know having now access to information
about how the label changes as a
function of input through these gradient
forms and now we can apply tensor
decomposition so we can look at these
cross moments and we can find a
decomposition of this into rank one
components and we can now construct I
know in practice so enough with the
model free approach what we can do is we
can just construct the you know we can
essentially project the input along
these directions apply some
non-linearity and use them as features
for classification so that's the overall
framework that you know will construct
these core function features and that
requires only unlabeled data and now
once we have labeled data we can
construct cross moments between the
label and these core function features
and what we established is that these
cross moments capture expected gradients
of the label as a function of input so
we can incorporate these moments and
find spectral decomposition and then we
can use them to extract discriminative
features right so this is the overall
framework now we'd like to ask how can
we use this to provide guarantees for
learning those conditional latent
variable models right so what kind of
guarantees does this method have so
let's revisit the mixture of classifiers
model so here now we posit that the
label is generated and now as a mixture
of different classifiers so this G is
some non linear function and so now H is
selecting one of the classifiers so now
what we show is if you if you can
construct the score functions of the
input and now we'll construct these
moments between the label and these core
functions we can find the decomposition
of such a moment right so this is third
order moment so we can find the CPD
composition of this tensor the rank one
compose
directly correspond to the weight
vectors so by finding a chance of
decomposition we can consistently learn
the weight vectors in a mixture of
classifiers model so these are the first
results to have no guarantees for
learning nonlinear mixtures non-linear
regression mixtures we can learn using
the tensor methods and you see here that
even to learn this conditional model of
the label given the input we need our
input information we need information
about the input distribution so that is
critical to learning these conditional
models so the other results are in a way
of very excited about is learning these
multi-layer neural network so here I'll
just show the two layer one are the more
general cases involved so in the two
layers let's say there is this first
layer and there is some non-linearity
right so these neurons take these linear
projection and then apply some
non-linearity and then second layer I'll
just assume a simple linear combination
for now so we have now the first layer
is nonlinear the second layer is linear
and we'd like to ask cook you know can
we consistently learn the parameters
here great I mean this is hard problem
right because there is no force the
non-linearity and then there's a linear
combination and in fact this is just a
scalar right but what we show is if we
can if we have a correct estimation of
the score function of the input we can
correctly estimate the weights of the
first layer in fact the again the you
know Rank 1 representation of this the
you know the CP representation of this
tensor will be exactly the different
weight vectors of the first layer so and
in fact the identifiability result also
states that this model has to be
non-linear here so this mapping here has
to be non-linear and the sample
complexity also depends on how nonlinear
this model is so we can you know
correctly we can kind of transparently
have conditions that characterize what
kind of
no nonlinear she is required for
learning these models consistently so
now I don't have time for details but
the you know now interesting thing is
even with now an additional layer we can
still uncover what are the character
weights are in this first layer of the
neural network and we just have some
preliminary results on yeah what's the
what's the distribution rates that this
s3 was posted so any arbitrary
distribution right so if we had this I
you know access to that distribution so
we'd like to estimate it and again
there's a whole methodology to how to
correctly estimate these core functions
but here we are assuming suppose we have
the correct estimates for the score
functions so it can be any arbitrary
input distribution and based on that
input distribution we construct these
core functions and the non-linearity so
it has to be any non linearity that has
like derivatives up to third order that
has a nonzero third order derivative
that's because we are looking at third
order moments here and in fact we can
even make it more transparent for
specific nonlinearities I mean the
popular one is a rectified linear unit
or the relew so we give a precise
conditions on when that model becomes
identifiable and I can discuss more
offline about that and but you know so
this now kind of has a nice intuition
that non-linearity is critical for
identifiability as well as learning of
these multi-layer neural networks and
our framework directly exploits that
fact here and so we only have some
preliminary results currently for M&S
data and we are you know now scaling
this up too many other models and you
know we're very excited to see some nice
results just based on even you know
without much tuning so the idea was even
for score function we just use the auto
encoder framework so we could have done
more sophisticated score matching
algorithms but we just did this simple
auto encoder we trained out
encoders and then we construct its core
function using the Taylor series
approximation argument for these are
reconstructed you know functions from
the auto encoder and then we can find
this crossbow bands and then we find
intensity composition of this and then
we can extract the you know directions
from this tensor decomposition and then
you know construct these discriminative
features that we feed to an SVM and so
what we found was results of the range
of like 96% just with you know just with
one layer of such framework and you know
so we are now trying like now multi
layers and we are also trying you know
much more challenging datasets using
this framework so to conclude you know
we found these tens of methods to be
highly effective too for learning
conditional latent variable models as
well so the idea is even to estimate the
label given the input it's crucial to
incorporate the input distribution so
and these we saw that score function
features are relevant forms of relevant
information about the input distribution
that's needed for estimating these
conditional models and the idea was to
find like cross moments between the
label and these core function features
and to do tensor decomposition and given
that chance of decompositions are very
fast and scalable we can be no majo
apply them to large-scale data sets as
well as in theory we get all these nice
consistency guarantees using those
methods and you know as a general
framework we have a number of other non
convex methods that we are looking at
and the question is you know we are kind
of building more and more class of
problems where we can establish
guarantees about non convex methods so
encourage you know more for people to
think about non convex methods as not
just going to a local optimum but when
we can obtain guaranteed solutions and
this piece of work isn't
elaboration with my excellent students
maji the honey and near engine and the
papers are available on my website for
more details thank you theory of time
for one quick question of does this
matter okay so I mean theoretically you
have to this assumes that you have the
right score functions right you have the
right estimate of the score functions
and the question when we can learn this
is a whole other question and there are
some you know like there's a body of
work on that but you know sorry in this
work what we are assuming is if we can
get the input distribution right we can
also learn this conditional model
sufficiently so that's the message of
this story and we got a recurrent neural
network yes we are looking at that as
well I believe we can give guarantees so
we have you know so this is something
we're working on currently